lo primero que habría que decir aquí o
analizar aquí es que la convocatoria que
hace el presidente de la asamblea
nacional no es una convocatoria para
dialogar sino más bien para discutir el
proceso de la institución del presidente
de la república el señor guillermo lasso
en este sentido habría entonces que
determinar que el día de hoy el país
vive una situación bastante tensa
bastante difícil porque está en manos de
la asamblea nacional el día de hoy
discutir si continúa o no continúa el
señor guillermo lasso en a su cargo como
presidente de la republica llamados a
dialogar entre el presidente de la
república y el presidente de la conaie
señor leonidas iza anas han estado desde
hace 13 días sin embargo este diálogo no
se ha podido concretar este diálogo no
ha podido ser posible y lamentablemente
la mediación para los procesos de
negociación de manera interna no han
sido efectivos y esto ha hecho que la
bancada un es de la asamblea nacional
proponga o haga el pedido de destitución
ante el presidente de la asamblea
basados en lo que establece el artículo
130 de la constitución de la república
del ecuador- numeral 2 esto es por la
grave crisis económica y conmoción
interna por lo que se seguirá el día de
hoy el procedimiento establecido tanto
en el mencionado artículo como en el
el establecido en el artículo 51 de la
ley de la función legislativa bueno
justamente esto estaba mencionando que
el 'panorama le espera al jefe de estado
entonces en la asamblea muy bien de
acuerdo a lo que establece la propia ley
de la función legislativa para que el
presidente de la república pueda ser
destituido necesita de la tercera parte
de los votos de la asamblea hoy en día
el presidente de la república se puede
decir que cuenta con el apoyo no vamos a
decir en la mayoría pero ha sido una
gran parte que ayudaría a que él se
mantenga en el cargo
para hablarlo numéricamente estas son
asambleístas nacionales de estos 137 se
necesitaría para que pueda proceder la
destitución de presidente de la
república del ecuador- 92 votos
son contando los de la bancada aún es
más a aquellos que están aliados
llegamos nomás a 88 votos entonces
matemáticamente hablando no alcanzarían
no alcanzarían los los números para que
pueda ser destituido abogada billón a
usted muchas gracias por este análisis y
por compartirlo con nosotros en france